my name is Tom I'm a software engineer
at LinkedIn where I work on projects to
make sure that our site feels fast for
everyone and that includes people who
are in emerging markets where many
people's first time on the web will be
through a smartphone it'll be their only
device and when we talk about web
performance we often talk about an app
being fast or slow but there's no single
fast or slow access instead there are a
number of axes along which an app can be
fast or slow and I think if we break
these axes into two broad categories we
can talk about them first an app being
lightweight that means that when someone
taps a link that goes to your site they
see something instantly a second we want
a responsive app we want something that
responds instantly any time that you tap
or swipe or click even if the page isn't
fully loaded yet and usually these two
things are in tension these things fast
usually means having a bare minimum of
code having a bare minimum of work
happen during that initial render but
staying fast requires being smart about
how we update the Dom and the smarter we
want to be the more code we have to load
so many compete many people consider
using a virtual Dom library to be the
state-of-the-art way to build web
applications this is an illustration of
a virtual Dom user achieving level 19
enlightenment now the virtual Dom was a
revolutionary idea because it
prioritized initial render speeds and I
think it's no coincidence that the
virtual Dom has become this massively
popular idea in the age of the
smartphone because users expect to see
something right away when they tap a
link it's critical that we build apps
that start fast but like with any
engineering decision
this comes with trade-offs for one thing
JSX compiles to JavaScript which comes
with parsing and compiling overhead and
most implementations of the virtual Dom
render the component hierarchy
synchronously which can lock up lower
end devices as your component hierarchy
starts to grow and to maximize initial
render performance and to minimize file
size virtual Dom libraries tend to have
relatively inefficient updating
performance so it becomes you the app
developers responsible
to efficiently track state and make sure
those updates are optimized and I want
to be clear here libraries that
implement the virtual Dom are fantastic
productive tools engineering is all
about trade-offs and these are the
trade-offs that the virtual Dom has made
but today I want to explore an
alternative approach to building web
applications that leans on new api's new
capabilities in the browser that didn't
exist when the virtual DOM was created
to see if we can try to push the
state-of-the-art forward and most
importantly it's an architecture for
what I would consider to be the next
generation of the web ready to take
advantage of new low level capabilities
like web assembly web workers and so on
people used to consider javascript a toy
language that you couldn't use to get
real work done but no one thinks that
anymore and if there's one thing I want
you to take away today it's that we can
stop viewing HTML template languages as
underpowered toys instead view them as
first-class functional programming
languages that we can optimize to
squeeze the maximum performance out of
even low-end smartphones so today we're
going to explore this idea by focusing
on three performance optimizations the
first one we'll talk about is what I'll
call instant templates so one reason
that web developers care a lot about
keeping asset sizes down is because
larger files of course take longer to
download but even on the fastest network
and even coming from a cache there's
still a cost that many developers miss
how long it takes to parse and compile
your JavaScript on many devices the time
that parse and compile take can easily
outweigh the cost of downloading those
files themselves and the shift to mobile
exacerbates this JavaScript parsing
compile can be up to 5 times slower on
mid-tier mobile devices so an app that
loads relatively quickly on your desktop
can suddenly feel really slow when you
run it on a cell phone and this is a
problem because even though JSX
looks like HTML when we build our app
JSX is turned into normal JavaScript
with the parse and compile costs that
come with it so one of the
recommendations that you'll see to
improve the start times of your web
application are to shift less JavaScript
but shipping less Java school
is far easier said than done how do you
ship less JavaScript when even just
adding HTML to your web app ultimately
gets turned into JavaScript that the
browser has to parse and compile so
let's take a look at a different way of
doing this we'll use the open source
library that I work on called glimmer
AAS and handlebars templates like you
see here - in these examples but I would
ask you to focus on the high level ideas
not any one particular implementation so
the key insight here is that we can
treat handlebars as a declarative
functional programming language
optimized for building and updating the
Dom think of it more like Elm or closure
script than a traditional string-based
templates most of limors code base is
the compiler we move as much of the
complexity as we can out of the runtime
and into the compiler meaning less code
to download less work for the browser's
to do now the glimmr compiler takes in
all the component templates in your
application it parses them and it
compiles them into something that can
run in the browser building and updating
your Dom but what does it compile them
into so JSX we know gets turned into
JavaScript but clemmer compiles
templates into bytecode glimmered
bytecode is a binary format that encodes
an executive or program well similar an
idea to virtual machines like the JVM or
Microsoft CLR glimmers instruction set
is specialized for inter operating
between the Dom on the one hand and your
applications JavaScript components on
the other so if we look at a decompiled
version of this program we can see the
various instructions our templates have
compiled into if you've ever been
exposed to assembly language I hope that
this looks somewhat familiar to you but
our instruction set is designed for this
inter up between the DOM and components
so after the compiler compiles your
templates into byte code this binary
data is sent to the browser where it is
executed on this small virtual machine
library it's a small JavaScript library
that knows how to run these programs and
one of the advantages of compiling to
byte code is the file size so here's the
binary output after we've
pile this template with glimmer we have
some additional JSON metadata you see up
there that we produce also and together
these are this template compiles to 179
bytes which is smaller than the compiled
output for either JSX or for example
angular's äôt compiler but the important
idea is that when you're not constrained
to emitting valid JavaScript you
actually have a lot of freedom to design
a more compact format which can be
faster to download which I hope is
intuitive just by looking at the example
here but we mentioned previously that
download time is only part of the
equation let's talk about parsing and
compiling talk it's cost people often
think of parsing as being so fast it's
essentially free but the complexity of
the language that you're parsing makes a
big difference for example json.parse is
almost ten times faster than javascript
because it's a much simpler language but
here's the thing about using precompiled
binary bytecode there is no parse by
sending binary data in a format that
doesn't require any processing on the
client we can skip the parsing step
entirely thank you for indulging my
keynote effects here glimmer uses binary
data directly with no parse or other
intermediate processing step and you can
see this in the excerpt from the glimmer
source code we initialize aun sixteen
array to operate directly on the binary
data that we get over the network
nope our step so here's an artificial
benchmark I created to stress test the
initial rendering performance I wrote a
script that downloaded 50 random
Wikipedia articles and converted them
into both handlebars templates and JSX
one component for article and I want to
get the sense of how limors initial
render performance compared on low-end
hardware which is an area where the
virtual Dom approach has always excelled
at in fact it killed us member so this
is a video of the reacting glimmer
versions of the app running side by side
this is running on a hand-me-down galaxy
s3 connected over Wi-Fi so what you're
about to see is CPU bound so we're still
waiting here for both of these it's
gonna take about about 10 seconds per
okay so the glimmer one pops up and then
a half second behind it the rack phone
pops in now I know what you're thinking
that
a horrible demo the glimmer and the
react apps both took way too long to
load and they both finish rendering it
about the same time right like basically
indistinguishable and yeah maybe it's
not a good demo but actually I think
that this is really impressive because
react set such a high bar and the fact
that glimmer is competitive on initial
render which remember is the thing that
that made virtual Dom stand out in the
first place the fact that we can get
close within spitting distance of it I
think is a good sign
virtual Dom is all about getting that
screen on getting content on screen as
fast as possible so if we can meet or or
match or beat that performance
we're already headed in the right
direction so that's the idea behind
these instant templates by moving the
complexity into the compiler we can
shrink the size of the runtime compiled
bytecode is smaller than the equivalent
JavaScript to download and no parse is
faster than no parse so let's talk about
number two next optimize updates and
these are some cases where we can start
to not just match virtual Dom and
performance but actually start to beat
it by default so remember that loading
quickly means being lightweight and
being lightweight usually means making
very hard trade-offs one of the
trade-offs of virtual Dom based
libraries including react is that being
fast by default on initial render is
more important than being fast on
updating renders and I want to make it
clear here that again I agree that this
is the right trade-off to make if you
have to make it but one downside of this
is that while the initial render is very
fast it's really easy to get into
situations where your app starts to feel
sluggish so there was a really great
blog post about diagnosing and fixing
issues like this called reactive slow
reacts is fast by Francois Zen and Noto
francois doesn't have to be in the
audience know well the name like that I
thought it was possible
Francois says what makes a react app
slow is most of the time
useless rear Enders of many components
you may have read that the react of
virtual Dom is very fast that's true but
in a medium-size app a full redraw can
easily rerender hundreds of components
even the fastest virtual Dom templating
engine can't make that in less than 16
milliseconds the react documentation is
very clear about the way to avoid
useless rear Enders
component update it's your job as a
developer to check that the props of a
component didn't change and skip
rendering altogether in that case so
this is just one of the trade offs one
of the downsides of JSX right your
render method is this black box that the
system can't see into because it's
evaluating arbitrary JavaScript so let's
see how adopting a virtual machine
architecture allows us to implement
additional optimizations that make
updates when needed extremely fast so
earlier I told you about the glimmer VM
but or what I haven't told you is that
these are actually two virtual machines
in one and that's because there are
fundamentally two types of operations in
any Dom rendering engine there's
creating Dom elements that don't exist
and then there's updating Dom elements
that do if the Dom nodes for component
already exist is hopefully obviously
much faster to update those notes when
component state changes instead of just
throwing them away and creating full cel
new nodes so let's imagine the very
simple template like this so as a human
you can look at this and you can
instantly recognize that only one part
of this template is ever going to change
so how do we give our programs the
ability to have that same intuition that
we have as humans so like we discussed
earlier on the right is the byte code
that the glimmr compiler generates for
this template but that byte code is only
for the initial render we use a
technique called partial evaluation to
generate an optimized byte code only for
updates so let's see how this works for
just for a moment we're all going to
pretend that we are the glue mer VM and
we're going to execute this byte code so
here's that same program that you just
saw on the Left we are representing the
sequence of opcodes as rectangles
starting from top to bottom and we're
going to execute each one of these in
order and as we do that we have a Dom
element in the upper right corner that
we're going to build together okay so
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to execute this open element
opcode and it's like cool it's going to
create a new empty div element next the
static adder instruction sets the class
attribute to active so we're going to do
that the next two instructions are not
particularly important to understand but
if you're curious they are pulling data
out of JavaScript and pushing it on to
the virtual machine stack
but now we get to the really interesting
part so first the dynamic content opcode
is going to do what you probably expect
which is to take the value of first name
and add it as a text note that Dom
element that we just created but in
addition to creating the new text node
the dynamic content opcode is also going
to tell the VM how to update itself if
anything ever changes and it does this
through something that we call the
update program so when we execute the
dynamic content opcode it's also going
to add an update dynamic content opcode
to the update program so lastly we
execute the clothes element opcode which
tells the VM basically this element is
done ready to be put into the dom now
what happens when we detect that the
first name property has changed instead
of running the full append program all
over again which has up codes for
creating Dom elements that we know
already exists we're going to run the
optimized update program that only has
to worry about updating the dynamic
parts of the template so we run this one
opcode and the program updates and bytes
so by generating the specialized update
program we can drastically reduce the
amount of work required in many common
scenarios and best of all by generating
the updating program as a byproduct of
executing the initial program we only
need to include one version in the
bytecode saving precious file size so
let's take another look a demo of this
in action so we're gonna look at our
Wikipedia stress test again and we're
going to make one small change to the
source code so here's our main our main
component react on the left glimmer on
the right and we're going to just add a
counter that updates as fast as the
browser will let us so we're going to
use set interval with a timeout of zero
and every time our callback is called
we're just gonna increment that counter
by 1 and then we're going to display
that counter using an h1 at the top of
the component so small enough change
right let's run that on our Samsung
Galaxy s3 so this is a react on the left
and glimmer on the right and I would
call this a dramatic difference so
again this is a synthetic benchmark it's
designed to stress tests update
performance it's not supposed to be
representative of relapse it
intentionally uses an unreasonable
number of components to make small
differences appear larger you can make
the react version just as fast as a
glimmer version in a few lines of code I
don't want to suggest that's not
possible but at the end of the day
wasteful slow rear Enders are a real
problem in many virtual dawn based apps
worst of all they can sneak up on you
because there's no obvious point in
which they become a performance cliff
they kind of just get slower over time
and given the option isn't it better
just to not have to think about it
so that's optimized updates with partial
evaluation so we're gonna talk about our
last item here which is 60 frames per
second incremental rendering so your
browser moves things around the page
like any other computer program frame by
frame for the smoothest feeling
experience you want your browser to draw
60 of these frames per second
unfortunately 16 milliseconds isn't a
whole lot of time to get any work done
and we spend more than 16 milliseconds
at a time on our JavaScript by taking 70
milliseconds let's say our users
experience jank that unpleasant
stuttering unresponsiveness and of
course the most expensive frame is
usually the very first one where we're
drawing the whole Dom so during the
initial render it's common for users to
see this the white rectangle of doom so
this is what we saw on the first
wikipedia stress test right where we
didn't see anything but a white screen
for 10 seconds now the reason for this
is that most libraries render your
entire component hierarchy synchronously
top to bottom without letting the
browser do anything in between and
that's what you saw both glimmer and
react doing in that demo but because
glimmer is executing a series of off
codes what if instead of doing it all in
one batch we instead broke it up into
chunks of work and then we can let the
browser respond to the things that we're
doing as we do them instead of way to
having it wait for the entire thing to
finish so let's look at another
Wikipedia demo again this time we're
going to compare glimmer to itself on
the left is normal boomer and on the
right we have modified it to break up
the rendering work into chunks so pay
close attention because it might be hard
to tell the difference here
so this is the synchronous
implementation of that render loop
glimmers VM exposes an interface called
an iterator that allows you to execute
one operation at a time synchronously
this is the entirety of the incremental
rendering implementation users request
idle callback to only perform work when
the browser has it has free CPU capacity
available so by breaking this work up
into chunks we allow the browser to do
its work like draw the dom and respond
user events every few milliseconds this
keeps our app feeling responsive smooth
even on olders hardware I just think
it's pretty incredible that this massive
of a difference in implementations
you'll such dramatically different
results for the user it's a tiny Delta
in implementation and you look at these
results so that's 60 frames per second
incremental rendering these are the key
performance benefits that you get when
you start modeling your templating layer
as a functional programming language and
what's really exciting is that this is
just the future because beyond just what
we have now there are so many exciting
opportunities created by the combining
this architecture with low-level api's
coming to the browser
like web assembly shared array buffer
and more so if any of this sounds
interesting to you I invite you to play
around with these ideas in the glimmer
playground at trial emerge is calm it's
got this embedded editor that lets you
easily create components and templates
you don't have to install anything we
have this cool little easter egg where
if you click the pi button in the corner
like the net you can actually see the
compiled output like what your what the
binary bytecode your fluence will
compile into what's exciting to me is
that all of the low-level capabilities
coming to the browser between the
ability to handle binary data execute
tasks and threads run low-level code
with web assembly the line between the
browser and the operating system has
started to blur and with these tools at
our disposal we can start to radically
rethink how we build for the web that
change might feel scary but I think it's
an amazing opportunity to build apps
that are fast enough to reach everyone
no matter where they are on the planet
so thank you so much for your time today
I hope you're as excited about the
future of the web as I am